Okay, this is not the kind of thing I'm going to show you how to navigate through your
Atelier Robin program, hopefully you can see my cursor there.
That of course, right there that my cursor is on, is the Atelier Robin, an icon.
There's some videos up here that you can watch as well, but if you double-click on that,
you will get to the Atelier Robin program.
You want to hit Open Program.
Now, it'll always come up to the last program you had running.
So when you get our machine from us, I have already tested your program, so it'll come up
in your program. But there's several file folders in, so this reads out like a Microsoft program.
So it has the name of the Atelier Robin ARR frequencies, and it's got a little file icon.
See that little file icon? That means it's a file with different folders in it.
So it's a folder with different files in it. It's probably better interpreted.
So if I double-click on that, it's got another folder with different files in it.
And the folder is Dr. Cutters, Alpha Medical ARR. So these are all the programs that I have written.
So if you open it up, like I did, I double-click on that.
You'll see the first one has AA, so it comes up alphabetically first.
And your name, it doesn't say your name, it has your name. And then it has the orders,
modules, and it has my special sets. That's a file of a bunch of different programs, special sets.
The Dr. Cutters 11th harmonic pathogen kill programs, even though these are all in the alphabetical
list as well. But if you want to get to some pathogen, like let's open that up, so you can see.
So you open that up, and it's got Add No Virus, Aspergerless, Babicia,
bacterial infections, blah, blah, blah, blah. So you can run different programs out of that.
But let's say you're in this file, and you go, oh my goodness, how do I get back to all the files?
Well, you go right across to the name of the file says this. That's the file folder that we're in.
With all those, you can hit this little button right there. That brings you back.
So that brings you back a screen. So it's back to this screen, the AA, your name,
orders, manual, special sets, blah, blah, blah, and all the alphabetical list. And if we scroll through
here, there is, you know, almost 2000 different programs, then you can run. Oh, here's an influenza
program. There's several influenza programs that you can run. There's an infertility program.
You can run these. Many of these are our shorter programs, hyperparathyroidism.
If we hit run on that, it would only be, I don't have it connected to a generator. So it would show you
the time and how long that program is. Oh, I want to get back now. I'm in this program. How do I get
back to the other programs? Well, now I can hit open program. And it goes back to what I was at. So
this goes back to the Dr. Cutters alphabetical ARR with your name on top. So let's go into your folder.
It's going to look something like this Sunday night Monday night. These are all bold programs.
Remember with the Atelier Robin, you don't really need the foot bath because with the Atelier
Robin, you can run all the higher frequencies that you couldn't with the true rife or some other
rife machines. So let's go into Sunday night. Oh, I want to click on the little icon here
because now that this is highlighted, I can actually change the name of that. I don't want to do that.
So click on this. I double clicked on it. Now I'm in the program. Now you don't, this is the program
itself with the frequencies. You don't want to click in this and do anything because you would
physically change the program. Now you'd have to hit save in order to save it.
So you, most people don't mess this up. I haven't had very many people accidentally screw this up.
But you don't want to, you don't want to toggle in here, play with this at all. Now if I did,
and I hit, I'm going to hit enter, enter. I'm actually, you know, possibly messy up the program.
But if I go out of it, you'll see now I go back into it. It goes back. It reverts back to what it was
because I didn't hit save. So you don't have to typically worry about messy things up.
Let's say you run Sunday Nights program and you hit run, again, I'm not connected to a generator
right now, but you hit run and you run it. You're all done for the day.
And you want to get to Monday nights. How do I get to Monday nights? Now it's Monday night.
Well, you could hit open home. You're going to go back one screen by hitting open program.
So now you could go to Monday nights. So remember, well, how do I get back? I want to go back
to all the programs now. Well, then you could go over here and toggle this thing right there.
You see it says up one level. If I just put my cursor on there. So it goes up one level. It goes back
one level. So back to your name and all the alphabetical list. What if I actually hit that again?
Well, I'd go back to the Dr. Cutter's alphabetical list folder that's not opened. So I'd have to open it.
What if I go back one more? They're all in the ARR frequencies.
Well, what if I just open this up? Well, then you're going to go to the Dr. Cutter's alphabetical
list. So it's like you're opening folders in a file cabinet. So in this file cabinet is this folder.
I double click on it. Now there's all these files and there's some other folders in there.
What is your program? What is older values? What is the special sets? And then all of these,
this little icon is the file itself that contains the information to run a program. So that's
a program. In this, this is not a program, but it's a file that contains all your programs.
So again, you can hit open home, but if you're at this screen or open program. If you're at this
screen and it doesn't have that icon, you go over here. You click on this to go back a screen
to get to other programs. That's how you navigate through this. If you happen to mess things up
or drag and drop and screw things up, we can always fix it. So don't be afraid to try to navigate
through here to try to use some of these other programs. Oh, I have allergies. I'm going to run
this allergy program and you can run that allergy program. Or oh, I need to get back to my program.
Hit open program. Go back to your program. So that's how you navigate through the system.
Don't be afraid to do it. Even if you mess it up, we could correct it. You're not going to be able
to mess it up. Just don't hit save if you're doing something and you'll be safe. All right. Happy
Ruddy and Frequency's.